Alright guys, so here is the last example and example number two for the daily bias.
So I'm looking at US Swiss and you can see that we have taken out this external liquidity
here.
So if I play this through, you can see that our draw on liquidity.
Where is it?
Can you notice where it's going to be a drawn liquidity?
It's right here, this Fair Valley gap around here.
So this is going to be a drawn liquidity.
Let's go to the hourly time from remember for the daily, we go from daily to hourly
and then to five minutes.
So right here, what do you see we have a shift in the market structure happening right here.
Cool.
Now where is the Fair Valley gap?
The Fair Valley gap is right here, that should be your bread and butter entry model.
So let's see price goes up to that level.
Guys, goes into this Fair Valley gap.
So that could have been your entry, we are not going to talk about the five minute time
from at the moment, but later on the video.
So don't worry later on the course, okay, so don't worry.
Your stop goes here and your take profit just goes here.
So let's see how this plays out.
This goes ahead, it fills in this inefficiency and right away, we have a retake profit level
hit.
So now that you have known about monthly, weekly and daily bias and external and internal
liquidity, remember I always personally go from external to internal.
You can try messing around with internal to external, but I wouldn't recommend it, okay.
So that was pretty much it for this chapter.
Let's move on to the next topic and that is going to be a game changer as well.
See you guys.